[Música]
el evento de revista de prensa con rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida muy
bueno mañana vamos a abrir esta sección
entonces con un tema de aquí donde está
basado france24 en español hablamos de
colombia y dice porque están matando a
los guardias indígenas es un reportaje
de maría fernanda fisher al en cambio
colombia exactamente buenos días raúl
como comentábamos el lunes ha vuelto a
renacer esta revista y durante esta
primera semana de publicaciones los
contenidos están en abierto y nos hemos
querido fijar en este tema sobre el
recrudecimiento de la violencia en el
norte del cauca pues aquí en este país y
precisamente pues habla la periodista de
que pues en el norte del cauca se ha
presenciado en menos de un mes los
asesinatos de seis comuneros de la
guardia indígena entre ellos bréyner que
cunha me este niño de 14 años y el líder
albeiro cama yo vemos aquí las imágenes
pues del funeral y señala la periodista
que en los seis casos es el resultado de
las constantes tensiones que se han
presentado en el territorio por la
esencia de las disidencias de las farc
más específicamente de la columna móvil
jaime martínez y precisamente en este
texto pues yo es ad hoc a uno de los
dirigentes del consejo regional indígena
del cauca asegura que los grupos armados
han querido deslegitimar el control
territorial y lastimar a la guardia
indígena entienden que no los queremos
en nuestros territorios y acuden a la
deslegitimización para atacarnos
libremente también pues en este texto
encontramos pues las en el análisis de
kyle johnson un investigador del
conflicto response core que señala que
una de las soluciones pasaría porque el
gobierno protegerá especialmente a los
grupos indígenas más allá de corona en
la pura presencia militar vamos ahora
hasta asia-pacífico rosa porque el
secretario estado de eeuu como lo
comentamos en la ronda informativa
anthony blinken inició una gira por la
región como lo analiza el 'global times'
bien pues el titular si te parece pues
lo citó directamente porque habla por sí
solo dice eeuu y australia añaden
tensiones en el pacífico mientras china
hospeda los los olímpicos para promover
la paz mundial este es un texto de
yancheng y su hielo y bien hace
referencia como comentadas a esta gira
del secretario de estado estadounidenses
por los países aliados de este diálogo
de seguridad 4 y lateral eeuu india
japón y australia y bien lo que excita
este texto vemos que la imagen también
es pues muy
explicativa por sí sola no vemos aquí
pues eeuu y utilizando un poco al
canguro representando a australia para
hacer de su matón contra china dice que
japón india y australia son peones en el
ajedrez geopolítico para provocar a
china peones de eeuu se entiende y que
esta provocación es irresponsable y
estúpida y que puede dañar la paz
regional y desencadenar una carrera
armamentística y señala que tanto a
cuate está este diálogo cuadro lateral
como august este otra alianza de eeuu
australia y reino unido
son las fuerzas externas que socavan la
seguridad y la estabilidad en sus
regiones adyacentes comunes a las que
hacían referencia pues xi jinping y
vladimir putin en ese comunicado
conjunto que realizaron recordemos el
viernes pasado cuando putin d se
desplazó a beijing por la inauguración
de los olímpicos de invierno rosa
enlazamos con algo entonces de sar tiras
sobre la actualidad internacional y
repasamos viñetas del mismo 'global
times' de media parte también el
universal en méxico excepto con pues
relacionado con el mismo tema no vemos
aquí la viñeta que dice pues esa tira
hay en calumnia infinita de la 'global
times' concretamente del dibujante sin
guía pues vemos aquí a eeuu boicoteando
pues a la imagen de china a la hora de
realizar estos en juegos olímpicos
seguimos con mediapart con una viñeta de
sí y que hace referencia pues a este
inicio de campaña perpetuo no en el que
se encuentra macrón vemos aquí macrón en
moscú en relación a esta visita que hizo
al presidente ruso y dice nada sirve
tanto como el puerta a puerta en la
campaña electoral y terminamos con el
nivel universal de méxico un dibujo de
helio flores en el que dice armas y
gente no en relación a que eeuu a
finales de enero desaconsejó los viajes
a méxico precisamente por la situación
epidemiológica del país pero en este
dibujo el viñetista hace referencia a
este litigio abierto en el que méxico
recordemos denunció ante la justicia
estadounidense
estadounidense a los principales grupos
armamentísticos del país por a su
supuesto rol en el crimen organizado en
méxico rosa gracias entonces por toda la
información nos vemos mañana con más
revista de prensa pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día